from being pregnant the whole year of my
degree giving back
writing exams
after three weeks of writing exams i am
giving birth after three weeks of giving
birth i
go and graduate so when i graduate i
have a three weeks old baby i have my
other two kids now i have three kids and
i have i'm 20 i'm 32 and i'm like oh
gosh the world is against me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright xl an immediate
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders we are back
in africa with barton mia an
award-winning tech founder and a
self-taught software developer with
robust problem solving skills and proven
experience in building tech startups
incubators co-working spaces and
creating designing software in a
test-driven environment she is the
founder of the first african software
engineering school focusing on women and
girls and worked tirelessly to mobilize
governments corporations and civil
society to invest in women and girls
education
mia from south africa cape town how are
you welcome to my show 20 minute leaders
how are you
thank you very much i'm fine in yourself
i'm i'm great now because we're talking
and i'm so honored to have you here when
i think of leadership out of town i
think of people that are going against
the grain that are they're going with
their heart and
not unstoppable
regardless of what happens and i think
that the story that you embody in your
journey with helping empower women
across africa to be engineers and learn
how to code i believe you're a
self-taught coder yourself and i think
that's that's a story that has to be
told and i'm excited to sit back and
listen to it and so baratang you founded
the first organization the first
engineering school to empower women and
girls to learn how to code in africa and
that was 18 years ago today a lot of
people talk about this but 18 years ago
not many people did
please tell me
about the story walk me through your
journey and and i'm going to sit back
and i just want to listen as a thirsty
i'm an entrepreneur
so um
i'm not sure if
for the sake of your readers i'll say
most people might know about the
apartheid situation in south africa so i
had
gone through a schooling system in a
township township meaning previously
the underserved communities
so and
when i finished high school i did my
parents were very poor so nobody could
give me even a two cent to go to
university but fortunately it was during
the time of transition where south
africa was needing lots of black
graduates and they were funding lots of
universities so university funding was
very easy and i went to
university of cape town
and when i went there because i stayed
seven years in the seven years that i
stayed not um going to school so i
finished metric and state seven years
before i started i went to university in
the seven years i had raised the
fund i would call it funding seat
because you had to register in the
university before you get funding so i
had raised enough money to do that and i
had started
in that seven years i started a business
where i did interior designing and i had
i had very good solid foundation of
entrepreneurship because of the seven
years so when i got to university i was
a mother already i had two kids because
in the seven years i was too busy i
started business i'm a mother of two
kids
and coming from a township that was so
poor
and having lived in so much poverty i
had left lots of skills because the
teachers themselves were not good so i
received the worst education ever
and so my language skills writing and
communication ability were very low and
at the same time i had
a challenge with mathematics
um
so and i had registered for industrial
psychology i don't know what let me go
to the commerce faculty
for industrial psychology because i
qualified so i went
and i registered there i had i want to
learn the hard way that there was a very
wrong choice
um
but i moved from the
commerce faculty to bachelor of social
science
and still maintained my courses so what
they did in the faculty because first
semester so a semester is like six
months of the courses yeah it failed
every i passed one course the the rest
the other three courses i failed and
that was economics
mathematics and
finance so i i went to the faculty and i
said no guys i didn't come here to fail
and
the faculty
advisor curriculum advisor talked to me
and after she talked to me she said to
me you know i'm gonna put some programs
for you but you have to drop all the
meds courses because they're giving you
a hard time
but what she did for me that changed my
life what she said i'm going to send you
to
the
um
to the mets department you must do extra
meds at the mets departments because
they were offering mathematics for
people who are studying courses that
have messed that have mathematics but
they didn't do
mathematics so i attended in the
mathematics but i attended semester
extra med classes but it's just to think
logically to to have that ability to
think like a
to think about mathematical concepts
that you wouldn't think they appear in
finance
once they are there like one is a
constant for someone who didn't do meth
properly in high school i thought i
didn't realize that that i would get the
sum okay but i would struggle without
knowing what's making me struggle so she
said okay there's there's lots of things
that's missing so i'll fill in the gaps
and she did two things that i will value
for the rest of my life so besides
sending me to the meds faculty she said
go to the writing center they had the
university had a place called the
writing center go to the writing center
what they want to do at the writing
center
it's just to check your essays before
you submit to them to check if you are
writing properly and your thoughts have
been communicated well on paper because
i was all i had i was also complaining
but you know even if i wrote the right
answer they don't give me the mark i
deserve
honest
and she said to me do that so i want to
and now on top of being a mother on top
of being a student on top of
working part-time sometimes there and
there i now have two extra things to do
which is going to the writing center
going to english classes and the
university is forcing us to attend
computer classes because for me it was
the first time i touched a computer when
i got to the university and having been
the first time i touched the computer we
all obligated to ta to go to the extra
computer classes and you know it's a
black affair i always call it a black
affair it was only black students who
are attending extra computer classes at
the in that computer lab
so that was the beginning of my story
now i always tell people if you could
take a person who
went to a township school who received
an education that was called banjo
education
designed specifically to make sure that
black people don't become successful and
they don't go anywhere besides becoming
a teacher
i i and you turn them into the person i
would become
when i left the university because now i
had when i left the university i passed
my my finances with seconds i had first
in some of my courses in strategy in
marketing and consumer behavior and that
was purely because they
the teaching that i got from the
communication for from the writing
center and that extra math classes that
i got were so good so obviously when i
finished university
i
i went through a lot so i i was
exhausted like literally exhausted
and
so i i finished my undergrad graduated
and did my postgraduate diploma when i
was busy with my postgraduate diploma
funny enough i felt pregnant again and
now i have another baby and i was like
no post post
natal whatever stress was too much so i
didn't go and apply for jobs like other
people let me start this way i tried
i tried applying for jobs but
it was it was not in my space because i
was going through
that postnatal depression so i'll go to
an interview and i have all these
things that are going on because i just
giving birth to a baby three weeks
before i graduate so
i was like this is too much for me i'm
not gonna do this
and
and then i thought you know what let me
do something to keep myself busy
whilst i'm waiting to start start to
start working next year because i now
have a postgraduate degree in marketing
i've started now i'm walking around with
two degrees and one of the elite
universities in africa but it's
something inside me with this
post-traumatic stress disorder from
giving from being pregnant the whole
year of my degree giving back
writing exams after three weeks of
writing exams i am giving birth after
three weeks of giving birth i
go and graduate so when i graduate i
have a three weeks old baby i have my
other two kids now i have three kids and
i have i'm 20 i'm 32 and i'm like oh
gosh the world is against me
and as the universe had its own plan
i always said there was a concoction
for what i would become
and i didn't
because in that year that i said you
know what i'm taking a break i'm i'm
exhausted i'm not going to be looking
for jobs because i had tried the first
two months to look for jobs even the
last
part of my graduations that i had gone
further with my some of my application
to even companies like unilever i was at
the federal stage to go and work in the
marketing departments but my brain was
was not into it
so i i didn't want to sit at home and do
nothing so i would go to the internet
shop um
learn few things
and as i was busy doing that i realized
you know what
i had survived the university with
a with my first year it was like like
through a 10th and
rope i was hanging to being excluded or
surviving and if i didn't do anything
the first semester to say can this be
fixed i would have been kicked out of
university because the
skills that i've got from those extra
glasses is the reason i'm sitting here
with two degrees
and that was not offered in in schools
and the other thing that was that also
made me survive was i realized that
being a woman and having gone through
everything that i went through
made my life more
double harder being at university
because i had to do to juggle all these
things and many people would ask why
didn't you
raise your own why didn't you let other
people help you raise like the village
and what i came from poverty i was like
my kids are not going to grow from and
in the environment i grew in so i i had
to bring them with me to cape town wow
so and i still had a long story short in
that space of
one two months i made a decision like a
spotless decision to say i'm gonna teach
young girls
mets
science skills you know take all that
that they were giving me at university
like communication maths um in the
basics of english and i'm gonna make it
a small curriculum go to schools and
teach girls when they are still in grade
10 11 so that by the time they get to
university these little barriers are
removed
and they don't have to face the
challenges that i faced and you know
because i had looked around i was
involved in student governance i was in
the src i knew a lot about gender
based movement iran i was one of the few
people that started the woman
empowerment on campus so
i knew enough about what's happening in
the industry so i thought to myself
look the marketer inside me said do
something that's unique and when i
decided to do something unique i decided
you know what i'll focus on girls but
i'll focus on technology mainly
encompass it with the skills that i
received that would make me unique
and
focus mainly on technology and teach
girls computers
[Music]
wow
unbelievable i i need to take some time
to uh to to absorb the story and now
while i do that
when you
decide that that's your mission and you
have this conviction through personal
experiences that this is what needs to
happen to change the cycle because what
you're talking about here is breaking
the cycle right yeah i mean it starts
from
it's the cycles the breaking the cycle
started from when you decided to take
your kids with you to cape town said
they're they're not going to be in the
same cycle that i was in and you then tr
extrapolated that to saying actually
there is a continent-wide problem here
that i'm going to be helping resolve and
and so tell me a little bit about the
vision for teaching girls how to code
and computers and and and how you grew
that organization
so um
you know having started gail hype
in
18 years ago the first
there was 2002
when i was still finalizing my degree
when i made a decision but i wasn't sure
about it but 2003 i was dead sure that
this is what i'm going to do
so what i the fortunate part about when
i started was
i was the first one to speak like that
especially in my environment so the
apartments the faculty the environment
was full of old white males
so when i walked into the space
and there's these professors eighty
percent of them were carrying phd who
were phd holders and what and they
seeing this young woman firstly i looked
young for my age so they i was very
petite and skinny and yeah so the
assumption is i just finished my degree
and i'm starting the business and and
seeing this young black woman walking
into the space they were welcoming to
say wow you're talking that i think we
need more women we you know we we don't
know why women drop out of the courses
and they start giving me more
information
and they were very accepting to me so i
always say i had a
four year leeway or
four to five years um
lunch pet where i had everybody
mentoring me willing to work with me and
starting the organization was very easy
because i was mobilizing the government
so most of the funding came from the
government the resource in from public
um
owned institutions like the universities
are partnered with all the universities
to say
in south africa and mainly with south
cape to western cape because there's
many universities around here to say you
know what um you guys have resources
at the time the inter good internet and
good computers were found in
universities
so in schools i was doing the after
school program it was like an extra
curricular activity
and after school
during school holidays which you guys
will call it the summer or something i
would get the school school kids to come
to camp at universities
and to be fair and honest i didn't have
to explain much i just had to say hey
i'm this person i'm doing this this is
what i'm doing and i was welcomed and
the
i.t business was still at the formation
stages so the companies that were there
they were either doing training or they
were doing networking
and they were welcoming me because i was
not a threat to them
the challenge came five years later so
five years later now companies like
facebook up are beginning to be stronger
google is beginning to be strong on the
internet people are beginning to
understand what they mean what skype
mean what this the power of building
apps is beginning to be very
stable and strong that's when the
challenge came um
that a powerful woman who was
endorsed by the industry besides started
being challenged because what i was
doing now everybody wanted to do it and
you know it wasn't as i thought it would
be because i was on a grace period
funding was easy mentorship was easy you
know when i say mentorship nobody said
i'll mentor you i had all these white
male around me they literally gave me a
chair when i say you know people always
ask how did you get the chair on the
table
nobody
i didn't ask for the chair i walked in
the space and i was giving a chair and
everybody said here's a chair you want
to sit with us and we're going to give
you the guidance
the case of that was because i was
mentored by white males
i adopted lots of their characteristics
and their behavior and their way of
doing things and their
biases around how what defines a strong
independent woman without realizing it
and and to
to erase that for me of power
comes in a form of white
identity and things it's something that
would take me years to work around
because i i also even though i was
working with women bringing more women
into the space i was pushing this agenda
of
this is what you need to be like you
need to be strong you need to be
independent without realizing
no no no no
you you adopted something that that it
was not meant for
that's why
and for me that's why i can speak about
our unconscious
biases and speak about it from
experience because that's what i did
that's the welcoming that i got and
being given a chair i mean
i had never speaking spoken at a
conference and there was a global
conference happening in cape town
and
when they were looking for a speaker
amongst themselves they decided paratang
is going to be a speaker and she's going
to speak about how do we bring
technology into communities i knew
nothing and then they said no no you
just speak about what you do this is the
guidance you know i'm speaking amongst
professors and i'm speaking to all these
international people and they gave me
guidance you know now you you observing
these little identical
presentations of people of how they
present themselves to the world and
because they were giving me resources i
had inter i had all this policy
thinking that i was listening to from
their viewpoints
my brain in its own way
idolized or adopted that mentality
fortunately i had
i was black conscious in in in my own
right
for tech
i found a model that worked and pushed
me into the agenda
i was the one of the first
people that wrote the content for the
city of cape town's websites managed
teams and built everybody it
it was modeled from
[Music]
white male perspective
and
when i wanted to
present myself when i now i've learned
when i say now five years later i've
learned i'm strong now i'm independent
um i realize that's not what they like
also you see they trained to be they
modeled me now when i started
challenging them and then it becomes
hang on
we don't do that
and
that would teach me a different
thing in life that i would develop for
the rest of my life
wow
i think that i need to already ask you
to schedule for another episode because
i think that we're only halfway through
the story i even just started with the
story
but i think that you know with all the
challenges and and obviously you know
having not come from africa not not
knowing what what the apartheid wasn't
is like and and not and and you know
it's it's a it takes a
lot of perspective to be able to
empathize and really understand and i
don't think that you know
anybody listening to this can truly
understand what you went through but
having but listening to your journey
of optimism
and of abstinence in the positive way of
no matter what i'm being unstoppable
and and doing what you did until now and
and the
people that you've impacted
and and i think that's just admirable
and and that's something that all of us
should take with us and i really really
appreciate you coming on and sharing
your story and and i want you to come on
again and share and share
much much more that we didn't get to yet
and and throughout the throughout it i
already feel like you've answered a lot
of the you know the final questions that
i always ask that
by childhood and about what inspires you
today and and what i really want to ask
you now is what are three words that you
would use to describe yourself
uh i'm very humbled
i
am determined
i'm i'm a visionary
i'm 100
i think
i always say i i can be very
taking it to the spiritual element side
of things sometimes i would say god gave
me a vision
and a purpose and through that vision
and that purpose
nothing
not nothing that was happening around me
distracted me because i had a vision
nothing so whatever they they were doing
because you know people trained to me
modeled me and made me this powerful
force
by default when i started standing up
for no
this is not what i signed up for um and
they wanted to
you know push me down and do everything
they wanted
i was too strong because the vision was
beyond me
it was not my vision it was my purpose
thank you so so much
have a great rest of the day and i
really look forward to hosting again and
for sharing the story this was just
wonderful and inspiring and stay safe
and stay healthy
[Music]